entre midi et deux ans notre petit court
arena de confinement alors j'ai déjà
créé le tournoi j'ai mis 13h20 pour vous
laisser le temps d'arriver il ya déjà
quand même pas mal d'inscrits et je vous
les habitués on à banane rose la banane
verte qui a l'habitude de jouer les
premières places qu'il a peut-être fait
un petit frère la nuit dernière banane
rose qui sont inscrits vous êtes déjà
une dizaine salue l'homme chess alors je
sais pas si tu joues si ton pseudo c'est
pas le même sur che ce cas là je tiens
mais déjà le lien au cas où on attend
dans la mine et l'ebook en train de
jouer de ronger son frein pendant les
candidats salut bennoo nebbou qui
montent comme un magistrat proche des
3200 je pense qu'il a dû passer numéro
delà du site
derrière l'intouchable n'a qu'un est
juste pas contre qui les jours un ennemi
américain qui prend la sauce six hommes
saluent grand maître gims alors bonjour
trois plus de encore non je sais pas ce
que vous devez faire comme 14 n'hésitez
pas à me dire 3,2 sur un an +0 à ok la
petite poche de télétravail la caisse et
salue le charpentier jules houcke tard
jesse staff catch des commenté hier un
petit peu sous les mandats venus de thé
party 3 % + 2 ok ça va plus je sais un
peu loin général pour les gens lorsqu'on
essaie quand même de faire un maximum de
parties du coup en plus de brest nature
salut olivier salut guillot et salue
akinator non je vous remets le lien
[Musique]
salut baden fut lequel donc on a des
pots ici là les noirs il a beaucoup de
pions au moins deux peluches et d'autres
analystes m mais bon ça va très vite
c'est du pain ou pas j'ai pas fait gaffe
la cadence oui deux jours 3 + 0 voulu qu
payer autant et cette finale que tout
allait vraiment bonne pour le noir il ya
la tour at-il entre compressible de
gameiro mais je pense qu il va jouer la
bande du risque et refuse la nulle
forcément l'expérience intime même
signalé quoi
l'allemand perdant me laissez pas avoir
il a voulu près mauvais tempo et il se
fait punir il a même peut-être la paire
disque en deux secondes la battait oui
là tout près mots c'est beau jusqu'au
bout du coup ce qui va être assez fâché
jours at il tonné pour son bruit avec
ses adversaires
ouais
à 4 au delà de 5 + 0 ça commence à être
un peu long alors d'ailleurs ce soir je
vais déjà un petit air ils vont être
gros s'arrête encore bien plus
importante que celle ci c'est à partir
de 22h30 s'est organisée par la fée des
célèbres d'inscription à tous
kevin commente rabelais jouera même
peut-être s'il est d'humeur donc venez
nombreux voir la pub à partir de 20h30
mener un peu avant peut-être pour vous
inscrire et puis et puis samedi voir
vraiment le gros événement caritatif
pour médecins sans frontières quoique
c'est à partir de ces laveurs si je ne
m'abuse avec maxime vachier lagrave qui
sera in fine paquereau son second filet
pour m vous allez à plus de voir fac
libye puis mathieu mathieu carle et
d'idées sera vraiment de faire un peu
des deux pour médecins sans frontières
ont toute la soirée
alors pour ce soir djukic s on peut
s'inscrire une heure pour le début du
tournoi à partir de 19h30
je commence donc à 20h30 où est l'info
normalement vous inscrire sur facebook
si vous avez facebook
je mettrai aussi de manière tout à
l'heure d'entrer dans le club se
prononcer
donc n'hésitez pas à les points et je
sais car ma voix je sais pas s'il y aura
des trucs à gagner peut-être que
qu'elles vont balayer quelques quelques
dvd de l'argent ça caille a rien
d'officiel prévu par la fédé mais juste
un gros tournoi y aura pas mal de boulot
je me tarde d'être encensé la fois il y
en avait vu quelques unes ya c'est juste
très mou couland 12,1 pique un peu les
yeux sont outils vous vous êtes très
bien depuis pas longtemps c'est un petit
peu dur à suivre ce qui se passe
je sais quelques mots prennent ment pas
mal de gens peuvent de décaler un petit
peu trop rire du coup ça va vraiment
très très petit un petit peu la chasse
aux primes c'est à dire que la garde des
petits pièges on espère que l'autre à
centrer move donc ça perd quand même un
petit peu
ouais ouais c'est pas vraiment de
l'échec c'est plus de réflexes aperçu
naissance en tout cas la pureté du jeu
et il vaut mieux pas être épileptique la
crise je pense ebit à rhinebeck pas
raison salut dont il est atteint c'est
qu'elle dit toujours que les pontons je
ne sais pas si le chap
le chat est exclusivement masculin où ça
à toutes celles qui nous regarde et nous
écoutons apprennent data je sais pas si
l'appellation la plus élégante de l'est
m 2 des groupes aux martigues a fait nul
je n'ai pas loin de là dessus on sait
que c'était passé inaperçu au bar à
montbard du haut niveau inscriptions à
part on a manqué de la fidèle au rendez
vous hier il s'est fait chiper la
deuxième place in extremis le tournoi
pour moi c'est le plus en réussite
aujourd'hui et je vais peut-être jouer
moi ce soir par un nouvel olivier je
suis du verbe avoir
je vais un peu aussi s'inscrit s'il ya
du nouveau distribué à gentiment mais
points elo
partout c'est le tie break dans ce match
deux poids lourds de 30 secondes j'ai
pas trop suivi du coin si les parties se
jouent autant quand même un jour arriva
à mathieu a trait entre autres
je pense qu'il arrive à jouer dans
l'absolu 70 ça se passe bien ça lui
mulipola 44 du coup est ce que nous
verrons les 44 tuer celui du tournoi
avec le même que celle là des maladies
troubles
je ne crois pas du bouddha oui ok acide
a raison j'ai perdu 10 plus jeunes mais
ils vont changer la cadence disputent
une c'est un peu moins violent bon sens
où tu as vu le monde super au genou
tellement vite que j'arrive à monter
jusqu'à 30 secondes la place de très mou
le fait de voir c'est d'avoir ce titre
un crémant verbe arnaud ça permet quand
même mais pas forcément de prendre leur
temps de réfléchir sur un coup mais de
pas tomber au moins saluer les kashima
écoute je vais très bien et toi moi j'ai
pas eu le temps encore de tester le jeu
dont tu me parlais ce que j'avais pas
mal de tap d'organisation pour trouver
en france des clubs online qui va
commencer samedi
donc j'ai beaucoup de choses à gérer on
dirait maillot rouge et à la semaine
prochaine je pense que je pourrais
essayer ouais j'aurais plus de liberté
ok tu quittes schéma est coûteux bonne
chance bonne chose en plus de cet être
un peu rapide pour toi c'est faire
plaisir
ultra méga beerbul est le dix secondes
carouge ont vu aussi une fois je m'amuse
à jouer un rôle en dessous de chaos mais
bon du coup sûr un chick est réelle mais
là ça se termine rarement bien c'est
vous qui reçoit le plus de pièces dans
dans la figure qui a perdu au japon là
par exemple booba a bien vu que des
incréments cette finale deux tours avec
trois puisque qu'il est nul vous ne
parlez jouer à l'infini
alors être filmé le lien allez les bleus
et bien tout je crois qu'il va y avoir
d'autres événements sur 13 comme 100
pages prend kodak redit projetant il ya
un très gros tournoi de blitz qui il me
semble se rappeler à tout le monde et
j'ai vu que maxime déjà parmi les guests
1 et on n'a qu'à moi
great choc peut-être fil rouge sam est
simple à suivre
j'imagine que primera et joue dans le
truck trouve à 50 ans j'ai passé dans le
chatt parmi vous et d'un serpent qui
aime bien sa carte un truc que je
réclame sa même tissé dispose une triste
pour le comme on dit si comme option
était souvent denneboom ça quand on est
capables tous les cinq ans moi j'aime
faire ça maintenant de jouer avec un
partenaire d'avoir avec 1,4 fou sur
l'échiquier
quatre cavaliers s'étaient pas installés
des questions
ja plus d'une vingtaine commence dans
dix minutes je vois deux nouveaux
notamment l'abattage rose je m'entraîne
beaucoup peut-être qu'elle perde a fait
des émules
c'est pas trop ça lui a world cup
éthiques
est-ce que tu regardes les matchs on rit
plaies des bleus allez les bleus ce que
je vois souvent n'y a pas pu match de
l'équipe de france en main de beauce
tadjik se passe ça marche bien ce truc
là j'ai déjà envie de regarder ça en ce
moment ça lui convient pas
du coup ils ont fini par faire nul dans
leur finale de toi infinie et à la
capote masqué qui est au rendez vous
s'est pas trop vu dans l'arène je sais
pas comment ça s'est passé
clairement quand il fait des perfs tu
lui crie haut et fort le chat donc je
sais pas si on continuera passé qui va
être assez fort pour les blancs ou
encore une fois c'est bien d'autres la
position est un déterminant 18 très vite
sur un petit dérapage incontrôlé auquel
tu es juste ans peut-être ai-je
personnel de salut alex vercel elle sera
quand même de football c'est ce qui fait
que les noix il devrait pouvoir tente
bien s'organiser après un blocus au code
noir explique je dis ça pour que qui
manquent un peu de temps alors ok on
sacrifie la qualité va en fait comptable
[ __ ] ici avec l aventure a gagné ou le
monde
ce que nous leur en vouloir être très
solide et mon big fish qui va
certainement mettre la pression sinon on
ne vous fait pas grand-chose bateau
qu'on a réussi à créer cette batterie
sur quatre mois va être très dur de
faire de cette faiblesse en dépit de la
crise a fait l'objet et même l problème
à perdre s'il fait pas attention à
cavalia a changé quelques couacs price
et matt la même si ceux ci s'était coupé
allemand retourner car il est trop fort
en fait plus la cadence s'accélère alors
le toit ce soir alex personne c'est
juste une tare est un peu standard
souffre organisé par la ffe doux
priori avoir beaucoup plus de monde
puisque une large publicité a été fait
en amont
donc voilà il organise hebdomadairement
en tournée cette semaine sur une chaise
ça lui redonne ok bah tant pis pour la
capote matière a pas de bonne surprise
avec toi aujourd'hui c'est le thriller
parfait des données déjà j'étais naïve
quote j'ai pas du tout comment sont
programmées les bottes à chaque site us
suisse est ce que tu peux participer
écoute j'espère bien j'ai été assez
choqué qu'une puisse pas a priori vous
trouve comment inscrire je ferais je
ferai la pub sur facebook dans le club
français après le relais je mettrais
donner un petit peu partout devrait
pouvoir trouver ça et oui je devrais
pouvoir inscrire vient pas d'eux le trio
petit patriotique a priori dans la haine
de soi lors du pit 7100 lots sur une
chaise comme qu'est ce que ça vaut
vraiment vide
c'est assez dur évalué déjà sa réponse
2100 alors oublier en partie rapide eux
parce que il ya une grosse différence
dans les parties lentes énormément de
temps pour réfléchir de quelqu'un qui a
pour hobby c'est peut être un bon joueur
pratique donc en fait si tu viens pas
trop en place vraiment quelqu'un qui
aime jouer le petit gars du mal à effet
très longtemps assis sur sa chaise
pour faire une partie de 2h 3h quelques
tournées vous sera moindre
donc c'est assez déficit et
d'endettement d'évaluer parce que aussi
létourneau en réel c'est très différent
cette atmosphère faut s'habituer à ya
plein de facteurs qui font un salut à
toi
revenez qui nous dit qu'il a
l'impression que le rapido rowling haut
niveau est le plus faible
alors non en fait c'est là c'est
différent c'est à dire que l'éventail
grand légende est cependant beaucoup
plus bas jusqu'à peut-être 592 alors
qu'en réalité c'est relativement bloqué
à 1000 lots même si maintenant on peut
descendre en dessous de 1000 c'est quand
même très rare et ça n'a pas beaucoup
plus bas je pense et on car c'est ni la
dune moins de 1900 alors que sur
internet des joueurs quant à 3300 donc
l'éventail est beaucoup plus là et c'est
aussi la raison il faut cela s'apprend
très dépendantes les sites par exemple
sur une chaise ça monte pas du tout et
503 points comme ya pas de réponse
universelle à cette question 16h04 aussi
les lots sont plus haut une fois une
chaise dans ce cas c'est que l'interface
pour c'est parce que nous on pas penser
est pas terrible ça l'à beaucoup
ces haltes et du coup je pense qu'il ya
peu de comptes qui joue sur une chaise
dans une pièce et aux non plus pratique
pour joueurs vous moi j'ai beaucoup de
buts beaucoup plus sur lynch est ce que
je conseille à d'échangés avant cette
chaise pourquoi bleach est ce parce que
c'est simple c'est pratique qui est à
refaire mute avec là guest on capote
masqué à barra je pense que tu peux
battre des banlieues jusqu'à peut-être
1500 1600 sur une bonne partie compte
sur une partie vraiment la notion un
petit peu un pacte coup n'est pas
possible on ne pourra pas votre carte
mais bien je crois qu'il jouera content
de ça son niveau toi qui est en bonne
forme qui trouve les bleus croûte de pin
bien se passait à 1000 semble-t-elle
jusqu'à 1600 mhz et sera pas là dorment
sur les titres contre et 9 qu'un seul
coup c'est vrai la différence par contre
c'est que des agréments 0,3 me sur une
chaise comme quand on prenne mon père
quand même voir un petit peu plus des
fois quand on la plateforme bram
alors le tournoi va bientôt commencer
dans deux minutes voyaient qui vont
refaire leur zone mais ça fait deux ans
qu'il doit vouloir faire donc c'est un
peu long suisse une victoire victoire
une partie remportée par la victoire on
devrait du coup tout kitsch est là j'ai
pas vu car outre un duo d'amy tard je
les ai vus en train de regarder une
vidéo étrange et beaucoup rigolé sur sa
chaîne qui peut varier les activités des
tribunaux ricard ou alors déjà à 40 m un
mot
foyer bar d'ariane pour l'instant enfin
mûri devons tous les cadres en partage
pour cette arène un certain pouvoir
et on va commencer dans dix secondes
donc on va laisser nos amis du 30
secondes ou disco tranquille et regarde
tous partis un petit peu plus calme et
j'espère à spectaculaire alors du coup
on parle directement par le chat quand
même pour commencer entre parme à ryadh
émigrés fu lei à 6,1 historique entre
les deux une écossaise
il n'a pas joué à la gordini pendant des
4 ici le congrès a cédé 5
c'est assez tactique en fait je pense
que dieu te connaître la théorie ici
c'est une relativement inconnu quand on
est des joueurs de d4 5 normalement
à l'arrivée les doigts ont trop de
problèmes et al ahly
las recyclé réussissent à un moment
donné évidemment j'espère qu'il n'est
pas stable et cette position à l'évoquer
pour les voir même s'ils ont un peu
abîmé leur structure de pions ils ont
quand même le contrôle du son est ce
qu'il va être important aux yeux de la
police au prince est de roquettes jouer
même si c'est un moment donné puisque le
rêve des blancs c'est sergio f4 f5 ou
quelqu'un vraiment avec les deux choses
sans trop côte à côte ils parviendraient
à au fond c'est complètement le roi des
devoirs
- les droits des noirs donc ça c'est une
vraie menace mais dans bâle dont les
doigts ont le temps de s'organiser pour
casser le centre de man au moment
opportun
on va voir si timorés volaille parvient
ici peu juste rocard était elle si tout
de suite tu veux vraiment pas se prendre
exemple peut le comprendre
on l'a prise
on parle beaucoup intéressant pour les
blancs parce que du coup on casse
complètement notre centre et surtout on
se retrouve avec une grosse pression sur
notre cavalier ici ghana dj chloé
deviennent fous derrière donc en aucun
cas où vous envisagez de prendre ou sur
m6 doit laisser la tension est
certainement
peut-être ces trois points intéressants
pour solidifier un peu notre centre
alors juste sortir ces pièces tout cas
ça fait réfléchir part variable qui ce
que j'ai eu en général tout plein plutôt
très vite là il a joué ses trois je
pense que beaucoup ici noir de broc et
pour pouvoir prendre ensuite sans que la
colonne des les empêche justement de
mettre leurs droits à la bride
je sais pas trop quel autre coup ils
envisagent que le petit road parce que
la forme de son développement voilà
petit rock c'est normal et maintenant
avec les bleus il ya cette possibilité
de f5 parce qu'il faut calculer c'est la
prison et 1,5 et là ça devient un peu un
peu le bordel toutes les pièces sont
reprises l'on doit pouvoir manger ici on
a mangé un cavalier on attaque le fou et
peut-être que les noirs ici vous
sacrifiez sacrifier la pièce en disant
que super cavaliers prend ainsi sa
revanche une fourchette mais parfois un
fou sur échec
le roi doit bouger on se défait le
prochain tome en jeu l'allemand jean
latour la subtilité c'est qu'à la fin de
la vacance et cavaliers il a beaucoup de
mal à ressortir
parce que toutes ces gars son contrôle
très compliqué donc je sais pas ce qui
va se passer
alors il a joué qui les prend des quatre
c'est prendre des quatre mais le
problème c'est qu'il va se prendre un
nouveau pion en de 6 voilà aussi ce et
maintenant c'est le pion pas assez
protégé en plein coeur de sa position
avec les doigts du coup ici même s'il ya
pas de pièce de plus pour les blancs
puisque l'avantagé nationale et des
normes alors ils montrent une attaque
directe sur leur one s'est passé très
récent comme un jour falloir finir son
développement ici un du côté de par
marianne mais en tout cas ça c'est
vraiment une très très grosse épine dans
la plus sûre noir peut-être vous un jour
se résoudre à jouer g6000 mettrons la
main fois en danger
saliba kunter à froid qu'il léger délai
oui pour pas que les joueurs puissent
vraiment c'est d'être nos conseils le
délai est pas énorme normalement
suffisant
après quand je commente leurs parties
peuvent vous aussi si besoin à voir le
fair play de newton si peu le stream
casser l'idée mais jusqu'à là ça n'a pas
trop impacter salut octobre
je rame et le lien au cas où tu welt
inscrire c'est pas le cas et du coup
comme je vous disais il a fini par céder
à la tentation de jouer j'ai six mots
griffonnés pourront donc à ce titre le
problème ici c'est très bien joué de la
part des barbarians la reprendre avec le
avec le cavalier lecavalier la dominer
le fou et surtout
deux fourchettes en espèces à la fin
donc du coup il a préféré garder les
dames pour éviter cette fourchette qui
ont été très dommageable et va loger
quatre mois je trouve que c'est bien de
jouer il va juste consolidé est un petit
peu gravé dans la roche sont dues au
tour là maintenant il est plus du tout
possible pour les douars de 2000 et
c'est toujours là jusqu'à la fin de la
partie vont devoir faire avec
alors en train de se trouver un peu de
contrôle sur carte blanche
il va avoir la colonne g mais quand même
les blancs menace cavaliers j'insiste
par exemple l'échec ne marche pas ici
parce que y'a qu'à 26 contre et chaque
ça c'est rare les contres échec mais ça
m'arrive souvent c'est très puissant
on joue sur le clouage et du confort ce
cas les noirs à sacrifier leur tour est
derrière cette pure hachette qui tomba
et du coup se serait terminée mais
beaupré faut là il va voir ça le
problème c'est que je pense qu'un seul
défense c'est devenu fou et vite pour
pouvoir manger avec le foot
les biarrots g6 ça sent quand même le
sapin ok le tueur le futur opus groupe
de tête je savais pas précisément du
coup c'est bien beau tout ça avec une
petite marge
alors dame j'ai cet échec
enfin deux dames chez cet échec on peut
regarder c'est que dans tous les cas
j'aurais pu être tour j'ai 3 donc je
parle échecs et maintenant au coude
après quoi qu'il arrive je vais mettre
ma valise rouge et 6 et là ça va être un
carnage
parce que si tu bouges le roi je
prendrai une pièce faisant une
découverte donc le coup de fouet vite
c'était vraiment la seule défense du
coup
passé et ufo évident moi j'ai vu ton
j'ai de quoi et avec les blancs le
problème c'est qu'il laisse vraiment
contre je spirou et finalement un
policier en train de se retourner
à l'origine un petit peu d'égayer la
barre yade avec les blancs il avait fait
le plus dur dans ces quatre c'est bien
joué parce que des fois il y aura décidé
à base de cavaliers g6 pour récupérer le
fou et surtout le fou a pas accès à la
casse b3 contrôlerait la promotion
canapé à chocs arrière la peine très
très bonne aso je pense que la bâtisse
est de nouveau retourné après pollution
est très complexe mais le problème c'est
que maintenant il ya le fou derrière car
là il suffit juste d'un match de foot et
ses gags est bon des fois les cas oublié
ce détail encore faire attention qu'aux
lois et dans les courants d'air mais là
chacun la découverte ici est fatale être
mat le coup d'après donc la belle
victoire des barbarians fait un petit
peu peur en milieu de jeu à un moment
donné mais la gamme fit aux jolis mots
alors qu' on va aller voir aller une
partie du voile khartoum au début entre
jonas ribot un autrichien qui avec nous
et au pire ah ben ça devienne une gueule
d'espagne à cette histoire mais on n'est
pas parti touré a disparu elle et des 5
km l'épreuve des seuils en 2 5i s'il
aurait pu juste défendre sereinement son
cavalier avec les noirs fougue et cette
fonte 7
avec la dame a complètement piste à tour
aux pirates
c'est le drame du coup il va jouer avec
une tour de moi où tu devrais porter ça
ok le futur au moins douze secondes
c'est bien déjà alain pour participer au
couteau héros est ce que tu racontes
tchantchès que si c'est le cas a juste à
aller sur ce lien il faut aussi quand
même être membre du club français parce
qu'on a un clic un vide avant c'est
gratuit donc j'aimerais aussi le dire du
club français si besoin
normalement au dessus de cet outil dans
cette partie le cas une tournette de
plus a priori elle est vraiment sans
espoir où se trouvaient quelque chose
d'un poil plus serré et ça ça va se
terminer
alors une particule ation des bus entre
hugo et star wars in sarrazac de joueurs
à peu près bonne force peut-être les
bleus ont pu déplacer mais ça devrait
être équilibré donc qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé c'est petrov ici les blancs a joué
de manière la plus haute
les deux joueurs se copier un petit peu
une espèce de miroir avec le cavalier
pour mettre la pression de soir les
pions ces deux essais 7 rebonds les deux
amants visa devraient s'échanger d'une
manière ou d'une autre
salut boulbina tard comme si ricker les
tours c'est de la merde les 10 5e c'est
un peu un spécialiste des finales de
tours pourtant premier adulte je quitte
chasselas et coup de barre avant c'est
un bon résultat
chaque demi point est bon à prendre
alors fou et 3 je pense qu'ici on va
essayer justement j'ai la perte de fou
et pierre moure et de jouer des six pour
défendre latéralement
c'est cette avec lada le point
principalement saddam hauts de seine en
début de partie basse et qu'on bloque
son développement c'est quelque chose
que je vous recommande d'éviter autant
que possible à part si la position d'un
repose il a joué à 6 pourquoi pas et
chassent le cavalier qui va devoir
revenir en c3 on décape d'ailleurs s'il
vient au t4 lui avoir décidé de chasser
le cap et on se sent tout de suite vous
voyez des thèmes vous faire attention
avec une prius et deux pour dévier la
damer le pion de 3 parfois la dame peut
être un petit peu surchargé dans ses
positions et donc les échanges attendent
yeux les plans bat noms font la même
chose et chaque cavalier et c'est eux
qui vont peut-être mangé l'option en
descente ou des simples stella il aurait
dû jouer des six avec les noirs vous
faisions était tout simplement pas
protégé mais ça dépend des strange part
du décalage arty grave garfunkel ici
pour les arts est vu qu'un du
commentaire de partir en direct auquel
vous avez accès le décalage léger et il
recommande par exemple maxime aux
candidats pour bas malheureusement les
joueurs n'ont pas accès à nos précieux
commentaires pendant leur parti puisque
ministre est beaucoup plus fort donc peu
importe le décalage ça c'est terminé on
n'a même pas le temps de voir cette
partie par une fourche d'atos et 7
ok là s'est terminée aussi
alors j'ai trouvé une partie ont déjà
regardé joseph ribault juste avant et on
à bananes rose ou la banane rose balade
rose belle rose n'est pas mieux réussir
s'est très mal passé d'un point de vue
purement matérielles romain calvi a
épluché la balade rose dont on essaiera
de retrouver peut-être la banane romeo
posture plus tard mon tournoi
une partie robot qui vient de commencer
tant j'aime pas trop de choses dans mes
cliques
les parties sont proches de la fin à les
haïr et c'est mieux d'amigo contre l'udc
ok et on est au tout début
alors ici pour les noirs vont
certainement devoir au ksk vite falloir
que vous ici sous cavalli apsys ray
attention maintenant il ya le projet
sept g7 qui était oubliée par ludo et
basse est déjà problématique en fait
parce qu'ensuite il pourra pas ok
lorsque hugo va le voir que dame projet
cette époque où très difficile à trouver
qui assure un gros avantage
voilà c'est joël fouet f6 hockey la dame
va repartir après siècle non on n'a rien
faire d'armes 17 gros rock et monopolisé
la colonne jam on peut avoir contre jeu
très intéressant sur le roi blanc une
toux et de voir si on aura le temps de
s'organiser à ses passions il ya des
problèmes avec nos pièces à des clous
âge donc
ces plans sont précis normalement les
noix devrait pas s'organiser si
facilement tendance la délégation
n'hésitez pas obligé qu'elles soient
forcément connecté à la partie en cours
[Musique]
il menace même de faire un grand homme
je pense qu'avec l'une blonde se serait
plaint de l'empêcher peut-être dame f3
essayé d'un coup ou attaquer une fois m6
qui a défendu par le cavalier très
simple si les affronts remplacer le
thème classique nomination du défenseur
mange la pièce qui défend et derrière
bas la deuxième pièce sera gratuite
donc c'est un bon l'objectif ici des
blancs de trouver un moyen de retarder
croire parce que sinon après avoir
grillé un tempo on va doubler les toits
sur la corniche et violon après arrêter
d'avoir projeté de plongée set elle a
mangé un deuxième pion donc au moins ça
empêche le grand roque je crois se
retrouve un peu coincé au centre
attention là comme une menace de maths
le voir la tête être g7
il faut acheter son vin rouge et 7 mai
avec la fermeture de la colonne départs
g3 les plombs devrait être relativement
à l'abri vous gagnez des thèmes pour le
développement il devrait faire valoir
leurs deux tournent de plus en plus fou
g7 ici par l'aquarelle coup joué
cavalier c3i l'échangé de l'accord ok
pas de problème
le seul danger voici six ans fut
arrivant du g2o h3 avec la dame qui
placent d'allonger de mai normalement
les noirs sont beaucoup trop d organiser
pour y parvenir
aum
du coup ça paraît compliqué pour lui de
trouver des choses pratiques qui sied
façon faut qu'ils gardent les dames
quand vous êtes dans une situation un
peu désespéré sur le plan matériel
garder un maximum de pièces sur
l'échiquier pour tenter de d'appliquer
votre adversaire
bah ça fonctionne très bien puisqu'il
agit de donner sa dame hugo ya le
clouage l'a jeté sur la table et les
ludo qui était aveugle et un pull il a
fait confiance quand son adversaire qui
a dû arrêter sa respiration pendant 5
secondes
c'est un double raté de mutuelles assez
incroyable maintenant il est très très
peur pas d'échanger les dames ça va
beaucoup mieux se passer pour lui dans
la finale bon ben isa par cette double
il a bien joué que les blancs mais là
c'était vraiment ce méga boulette
du coup c'est plus qu'une question de
technique on a deux qui ont de plus puis
à tours g7 est en jeu j'essaie d'aller
ramasser les pions on va parler et les
saints qui vient de faire un nouveau
petit craquage du corps il a un peu de
chance il ya une découverte qui lui
permet quand même de récupérer le fou
mais là juste à d'une qualité
gratuitement sans raison donc maintenant
il a capté son avantage la pollution de
à peu près égale ici et que qualité pour
deux pions jamais encore qu'en avant
même les deux pions attention la passe
pour une enfilade de cette fois ci la
vue d'un point
pratique je pensais plus facile à jouer
pour les bleus les bleus ont intérêt à
garder tour quand vous avez une souris
et une autre pièce milliards entre deux
tours c'est vrai que parfois il ya des
exceptions et vous allez retirer à
garder votre tour est ce que votre
adversaire il a deux pièces à grande
portée qui se déplace horizontalement ou
verticalement vous n'avez qu'une seule
si on a une de chaque côté qui disparaît
lui gardera cet avantage et vous aurez
plus que votre carrière votre fou qui
est limité donc vraiment ici gardait la
tour c'est important pour les blancs
on
du look et la pub 17 secondes mais il y
avait un créneau normalement ça devrait
pas être décisif ici enfin peur des
chèques pour faire des chèques pour ce
cavalier la porte davantage à f4 aux
protégés de roy attaqué la tour naturel
en dieu qui sait pas où mettre son roi
touquet raid pas un échec ici donc c'est
un peu trop se poser et si vous faire un
nul avec un échec des habituels vu jouer
avec les noirs ils s'enlèvent des échecs
auxquels du coup la tour taipei mais la
difficulté c'est qu'il ya pas d'aveu de
faiblesse d'après activer le roi c'est
bien si on peut la mener jusqu'au bout
jusqu en c3 on sait que ce sera fait
alors ça une tactique qui marchent pas
bien sûr l'idée c'est que si le roi pro
et la cour qui ont l'air mais le
problème c'est que croit tout simplement
reculer même si on leur faire des
chèques qui pourra reculer aurait avancé
et maintenant le cube est sera faible
donc se méfier des coups un peu
artificielle qui finalement l'effet de
la porterait l'âge ça fait joli 6 mai ou
crête - certains établissements plus
qu'autre chose ses pions là sont moins
solides que l'office des terres aux
baies 3 essais de salut mister pessoa et
oui car kader tôt j'ai peut-être pas
fait le meilleur des choix la scène a
atteint pour la partie conçu tous
d'accord c'est pas la grosse attaque
salut intel tome 21 là anthony mais on
va essayer d'aller jusqu'au bout avec
une petite fourchette qui se profile
j'ai pleinement gt3 c'était pareil ce
piège qu'elle a lieu cinq échecs
une découverte qu'on gagne et du
matériel il l'a vu après tout c'est très
serré la vis à tour ajoute alors allez
un petit peu aux oubliettes ici jouent
juste avec un tour du pin
quinzaine beaucoup servir de toutes ces
pièces aux échecs et un cash il s'est
pris un cap 6 échecs vont maintenant
normalement
en plus tous les pions sont que
complètement explosé on trouve touche
isolé donc donc du coup pourrait finir
par payer cette partie dans laquelle la
hem raté une date beaucoup à tout le
monde y est ce que tu peux et blé
phonétiquement tels tom c'est comme ça
que tous les jeudis un tel temps il a
dépensé a sinon fait de thermoformage
parle anglais
je suis jean s'inscrire dans un tournoi
par exemple naisseline puis en français
un tel secret qu'un débat grammatica
sans fin un tel tom hockin kelly dh et
derrière ce pseudo cette finale qui est
complètement gagnante
évidemment les pc des attestions ou la 3
il a approché du pion il a juste éloigné
nyse s'il a joué sur le coup roy et 7
qui du couteau vers la lune va donc on
va être l'inarrêtable sm on importe que
tout à gagner la partie
passé derrière c'est à dire que
conviennent pas ma conception vois pas à
quoi ce que moi dans la bande ok du coup
s'est terminée par une nulle
alors une partie en cours assez chaud
entre expo et drago no est ce que c'est
vraiment utile en tant que débutant de
joueur en bout de moi même
bah je pense que je vous envie de
s'attarder quand même un petit peu
dérouillée entre guillemets de prendre
l'habitude de jouer des coups de faire
beaucoup de parties du cou de voir plein
de chemins différents
alors certes tu fera certainement
beaucoup plus d'erreurs que des buts ça
va trop vite pour toi il faut pas faire
que des blitz plateforme attrait mais
quelques buts ça peut aussi un petit peu
entraînés tout dans une finition est à
prévoir selon tombe à quel point tu
débutes c'est mieux que la cades en soi
un peu plus longues malgré tout plus
gros progressent plus du peu de
permettre de raccourcir parce que tu
verras les choses plus rapidement
tourner elle sera plus affûtés du coup
dans cette partie on se dirige vers une
finale retour contre kung fu avec un
point de plus pour les noix la structure
d'options et août soit pas couleurs du
fou ici on va essayer de fixer
alors bye lot de choix certainement pas
le meilleur et peu simplifié avec les
plans ils essaient de faire nul de ce
tarif maximum échangés le plus de points
possibles ainsi que le pion 16 une fusée
essayé autant cette finale à la mène
avec des fous de couleurs opposées
il y aurait de très grandes chances
bulle parce qu'on pourrait faire un
blocus sur 15 mois mais ici par contre
avec les problèmes couleur c'était à
priori perdons maintenant cette finale
deux tours
elle doit être guillaume parce que
notamment les pions sont isolés donc le
roi peut facilement aller manger qui la
laissait le processeur qu'en voiture et
que les bons il n'a pas choisi la
meilleure défense non plus dans les
filiales de tours comme ça ce qui est
très important à savoir c'est que la
tour est toujours bien mieux autant en
défense qu'en attaque guerre derrière
luxe derrière le plot mode assaut à
toujours plus de mobilité liberté de
mouvement quand on défend et de la
tourbe devant le pion bien on est bien
plus passif oui c'est vraiment la
mission des bourses d'échangés de
liquider les deux contre deux serait le
rêve
mais si c'est pas possible
après ce site cette finale deux tours me
demande si elle est pas nul parce que
c'est un pion h
je crois qu'elle annule cette finale
deux tours
n'empêche pas sur ses dépens cependant
l'option peut pousser facilement parfois
des tunnels avec deux pions de plus il
pion à ce qu'ils peuvent faire nul si un
boxeur bateau c'est sûr que ça perdre
parce que juste il a tourné aux sons
sont progressé à l'équité d'ars
d'harceler l'euro à l'infini mais ici ça
pas perdre en fait ce qui est important
je dis pas de conneries c'est l'écart
nombre de colonnes entre les deux
options
donc le roi serait aussi prêt à donner
un coup de main des deux côtés ici c'est
le côté car du coup sa vague salut cp
well le lien il n'est pas donc ces deux
clubs français le lien de la reine il
est là j'arrive à sélectionner tac
dix minutes ça va aller après 5 min à
d'autres juste lui fait n'importe quoi
c'est normal j'ai pas depuis combien de
temps tout hamel mais trois minutes et
s'inclinent c'est comme déjà très rapide
au sitap a pas mal d'expérience dix
minutes au moins tu peux un petit peu de
poser sur les moments importants de la
partie
alors là alex personnes on voit souvent
dans le chat qui a les noirs contre
kalach
kalash le grenoblois bien l'école des
fourbes sur le gâteau des deux côtés
n'oublie la théorie est juste ou se
développe tranquillement on voit ce qui
se passe ensuite
c'est une approche mais du coup ici on
voit que les noirs dans le monde ont un
peu pris le dessus parce qu'ils ont plus
d espace et on va se retrouver avec un
pur on a ri avec les avec les blancs pas
forcément
matic ici aura des compensations avec la
avec la colonne clc apparu de gages
qu'elle décide sur wii les cas l'achat
et les blancs c'est c'est le grand
problème c'est à peut-être de chopper
edwards plus tard faire plaisir à 25 ans
aide et assiste à une belle kalach suu
kyi et des cieux moi aussi oui jean
beaulieu de coin d'une espèce de
structure détenue mardi avec ses 84 ont
trouvé des cinq sauf qu'il ya un pion
ses 5 point toujours joué ces six ici et
voir aucun problème
alex personne qui est très solide pour
l'instant on peut dire qu'il a égalisé
et l'idée pour les noix d'amandes et
pourquoi pas un cavalier ou des 4 c'est
difficile à réaliser un bouclage de
foudre et 4 d'autant plus et blanc
risquent de manger à tout moment pour
essayer de se retrouver qu'à un bon
cavalier contre est un fou pas terrible
puisqu'il sera derrière ses pions en
mangeant des cartes par contre là c'est
bien c'est une très bonne de mètres et
noir alès le problème ici c'est qu'il a
oublié son pion p7 à la fin de la
variante c'est à dire ici va y avoir des
trucs comme ça et la diagonale du fou
s'ouvre merveilleusement le pion
bessette va tomber du coup ça devient
très prometteur et voleurs cas ce simple
petit corse et si si si ouais vraiment
résolue par les problèmes toi parce que
si c'est ce qu'il s'est passé
desikan âge qui réfléchit avec les
blancs et il attend les 15 secondes de
décalage pour suivre mon conseil donc
pourquoi le pion au ghetto est très
peureux recommandé pour le coran c'est
vrai beau qu'une à tort ou à raison
ça arrive vraiment rares bons voire
absurde que toi avec un grand r je pense
que la raison principale c'est que le
roi henry nancéen du coup pas perdre
attendre plus pour aller au bénin et
avoir cette espèce de petit cocon à
trois avec le fuji devant lui le roi qui
protège le pion de l'extrémité la
structure qui est devant lui et que du
coup on fait quand on a le roi en c1 il
faut en b2 l'adversaire il peut
peut-être tout de suite force est
parfois des échanges avec la batterie
standard dame fou dans la diagonale tout
de suite des échanges de fou or quand on
met parfois faire du tout évident a beau
le but c'est de le préserver fou est
donc ici dans ses positions au moins
aussi un fourrage 3 dha plus facilement
la ressource de reculer notre essai
d'histoire d'ouverture la théorie de se
trouver comme ça de manière générale ça
se fait doucement petit rock band rock
ou c'est aussi pour ça qu'on voit moins
d'options de kétou avec en vrac
bah c'est assez long à mettre en place
et le dhj choix qui revient très bien
dac
si tu parlais bien de la reine alors
elle même elle qui le dit que j'y joue
depuis jeudi elle tu veux présumé je ne
sais pas depuis deux ans j'ai arrêté
plusieurs mois et là tu recommences
hockey et oui forcément c'était déjà
leur bagage c'est pas mal c'est comme
dans tout tu va réapprendre bien plus
vite que s'il ya du député complètement
salut perceval et karadoc alors je crois
qu'on doit aux fans de kaamelott ici
alors qu'actuellement il à cannes raté
sa chance que je vous ai montré qu'à
l'heure de de gagner deux pions mais
c'est malgré tout sa position s'est
grandement améliorée parce que son fou
est devenu très bon maintenant il a le
contrôle du centre est il
pouvoir jouer elle 5 ou un petit peu
prendre de l'espace et le pion des
quatre débats c'est certes bien protégé
n'est pas protégé par an qui ont donc ça
reste une cible le poteau ce qui est
certain moment tu y as vis-à-vis de
tournage et avec les plombs j'aimerais
bien drôle de madame de deux jours
qu'elle est mal placée f5 riche idée au
général tout moment mais peut-être un
coup de mer de hofu 4 j'y crois pas trop
un petit peu téléphoné ce genre d'
attaque
j'aimerais qu'on me considère en tant
que tel à quel âge j'ai commencé à jouer
alors mon père m'a appris à 4o les ai
joué avec lui uniquement jusqu'à près 9
ans et demi et déjà déjà j'aimais pas
perdre du coup je trouvais tous les
stratagèmes possibles et inimaginables
pour le battre quand il ne me laissait
pas gagné pour me motiver
en changeant la position des pièces par
exemple quand le téléphone sonne au
milieu de la partie à l'histoire de
compte ils reviennent ils se retrouvent
avec la dame aux femmes et comme par
hasard
évidemment il disait rien donc du coup
fort de mes nombreuses victoires contre
lui je me suis inscrit dans un club
vers 9 ans donc et puis très vite très
vite j'ai gagné plein de coups plein de
médailles dont j'étais très heureux en
tournée elle tient un gag même à une
coupe juste c'est tout ce qui compte en
fait
ensuite j'ai fait je veux at france un
paquet fois puis ensuite on retrouve les
mêmes têtes les mêmes
ça peut aller assez vite après je suis
dans une région les éjecter pas ultra
développé non plus longues et donc pas
le plus facile pour progresser par
rapport par exemple
grand club 19 ans d'un côte d'azur qui
avaient beaucoup d'entraîneurs et on
voit que les choses vont très mal tourné
pendant ce que je raconte ma vie à
kalach
il a perdu tous les clones son rock elle
encore insisté ce porte ce qui met la
pression autant mais là bas il a deux
pions de moi roy qui est faible donc
c'est assez dramatique ce qu'il arrivait
je sais pas s'il va réussir à trouver un
moyen de s'en sortir
j avec le noir le processeur juste
amener ce plus rentable même faire
attention mais alex personnes à savoir
s'il restait à prouver que ces trois
seconds ils en train de faire une perte
avec les doigts contre un joueur qu à
presque 400 points de plus que lui
non faut pas craquer aura le plus facile
c'est d'échanger les dardanelles 4 ou
rentrer en finale deux tours est
normalement c'est plus facile à gérer
avec quelques secondes à la pendule du
choix des lancers que le pion des si
c'est vrai c'est très bien joué il n'est
pas défendable
du coup a pas vendu le jeu et on a
maintenant trois fume boit tant mieux
pour pinatar et la partie à carémeau sur
le visage c'est alors s'était écrasé en
appel une tour j'ai pas venir parce que
si j'ai pas trop de doutes sur l'issue à
l'expérience nous a montré que y avait
le mental pour aller gagner la partie a
eu un dernier point efficace mais déjà
on fait ici riz
elles sont et qui a été jouée finalement
sa force était très bien joué de la part
d'alex sa force et les blancs à prendre
parce qu'au ballon évidemment leurs
restes de garder scoop à ses protégés ce
qui est vu que il a beaucoup fouet ses
propres pièces s'est retrouvé contre de
mojo m6
et tout de suite ça crée un peu notre
jeu sur la côte 1 2 il a pas fait
attention il n'a pas laissé passer la
tactique ans avec les droits cavaliers
pour les quatre très bien joué derrière
c'est fini adoption qui tombe il ya le
roi qui se retrouve affaibli donc
[Musique]
vérifier lors ils vont pas terminée
voilà ça y est il va à dame très mode
game d'alex personne qui a su plier
l'échiné mais il n'a pas rompu
du coup kalach tels que je connais a dû
lancer sa souris
donc il va terminer le tournoi ou touch
pad pompiers du coup et s'est trouvé
notre parti est en amour fo l'oeil
peut-être qu'ils allaient blanc neige
pas regarder le classement vite fait ses
cryptes awa cristal qui caracole en tête
il ya 13 sur 13 tirs pas comment il a pu
jouer autant de parties en 35 minutes il
a signé 13 parties classées juste
monstrueux et il a plus de la moitié des
points
ses poursuivants une cristal qui est
survoltée j'ai vu que tu as très sélect
bah écoute même cet astre et sata
superpitcher super bien géré la forme
est là exactement mr pc loi le fou qui
telles armes principales des plans
finalement leur a coûté leur a coûté la
partie ben là c'est une erreur tactique
tout simplement il a oublié
il a oublié les petits cavaliers pros 24
sa cuisse de caille de cavaliers étaient
terminées alors du coup mon gré fola et
comment il s'en sort entre autres bruno
bruno qu'à l'occasion des un contre un
joueur bien mieux classé que lui mais
j'ai l'impression que j'ai mieux que se
défendre déjà il ya égalité matérielle
alors pour l'instant sur le fouillis
c'est un peu la tronche mais pas de
panique il va pouvoir cadre d'une façon
ou d'une autre un petit peu le rap des
rongeurs mais surtout ce qui est
intéressant
position pour lui c'est que l mètres de
la colonie la saison nous plaît peut
investir la seconde rangée avec
cavaliers qui parraine roger 4 donc ici
à leur tour descartes comprend pas trop
ce court parce qu'ils se préoccupent pas
du tout voix de ici maugrey fallen a son
idée c'est d'essayer de jouer autour des
2 kg cadet alors quand même très
dangereux
j'aime pas du tout une position proche
ici malgré ce flou qui joue pas pour
l'instant le cavalier non plus d'avoir
une très grosse surprise avec kazim il
pointe mois et les doigts en plus très
grosse partie de bruyne os bada roche
est en train de bien le poids assez pour
qu'il craque d'ici deux trois coups je
donne aussi des cours d'échecs oui intel
et puis je bosse pour chaises comme de
manière générale j'écris des articles
j'en traduis je gère aussi la page
facebook twitter des stream avec vous de
temps en temps russie touchée a pas mal
de choses et on à la mairie d'istres est
trop bas après on n'est pas obligé de
commenter pas partie si ça te stresse
ans alors tour d2 a été jouée alors ici
ce qu'il faut vérifier c'est trop h2y à
première vue à l'air étrange parce qu'il
ya tour pro tour on peut intercalé un
échec derrière qu'est ce qui se passe me
fait ch eck dans la seconde en aux
jeunes et donc on va ramasser cette tour
où carrie le roi de toute façon donc on
aura gagné un tour au passage on aura
notre tour un salon secours auraient
donc jamais vois ça bruno va très bien
malheureusement il a échangé des tours
reste est plutôt pas mal d'ailleurs mais
c'était vraiment l'occasion de gagner le
point 2 un gros avantage
et là il ya perdre bêtement a gelé poids
serait comme annoncé en se prenant une
double attaque avec le roi après il
avait la pression autant c'était pas
facile
c'est dommage parce qu'il est vraiment
très bien joué
jusque là je pense que mauvais aloi il
n'était pas hyper serein mais tout
simplement une double attaque coûte une
pièce du coup la partie on voit que
quelles que soient les écarts et non
parfois il ya des grosses surprises dans
cette arène et surtout les joueurs quels
que soient leurs placements peuvent être
très dangereux vraiment faire très
attention à tchatche.com ccm mondiale
aux américains de base mais ils
développent aussi de ce leurre leurs
sites dans plein de communauté pour
plein d'autres langues en français
on fait beaucoup de choses la communauté
espagnole aussi est très actif il ya la
commune et russes allemandes mais un
petit peu tous les pays globalement ils
essaient de faire deux choses en voilà
on contrôle le monde
ces minus et cortex la version échec
c'est l'objectif ultime
si certains sont de ma génération pour
les dessins et les laisse à leur parlera
alors on va lancer une autre partie
cristal peut être j'ai aperçu gelé perdu
aussitôt après où est charlie ou une
crypte talent je ne vois pas
c'est quand même notre leader
incontournable
je vais quand même très très vite un
pourri autant de parties là on voit
qu'il a deux minutes à 15 secondes
il est en train de mater son adversaire
donc simplement échanger des pièces et
essayer de jouer tranquillement avec sa
qualité de la pêche reste et qui se
défend pas là la ville pour un mois il
est très loin d'être ridicule même si on
arrive en cours de partie
l'éruption pour la qualité ou
objectivement ça être perdants les
typiquement sûr d'arriver ici à liquider
juste les pions de la lll dame aurait de
bonnes chances de nul avec le 3 contre 3
ici
mais en france à travailler pour eux on
n'est pas si nombreuses à déposer
surtout kevin qui elle faisait des mois
et antoine aussi qu'ils bossent pas mal
pour la traduction des articles et après
on a plein de deux jeunes à mathieu
femme qui fait beaucoup de traits le
match de plus et avec nous et puis de
temps en temps on n'a pas des invités de
marque de maxime n'a elle tient
paquereau alors on va dire qu'ils
travaillent directement ou pour autre
chose comme c'est plus une question est
elle sans surprise crypte talent il a
conclu et du coup ils continuent de le
raser ce tournoi en jambon beurre il à
se faire mater voilà son roi qui s'y
fait on danse on which et du coup on va
changer de parti tout de suite la pile
où la pilule dans cette opinion je ne
sais pas pourquoi je veux qu'on folle et
hop et la pop l'animal est assez
différent notamment au niveau des
oreilles mais soit contre la pomme
bitstream dit furia et on a un
déséquilibre est assez intéressant une
dame contre tours cavaliers à la pointe
il ya plein d'options pour les noirs ce
qui fait que j'allais dire si vous êtes
gagnants mais c'est pas si facile parce
que ce roi il a un peu dans des réseaux
à trois êtres et actif ici en libye on
menaçait tour g6 de gagner la dame mais
bon il ya peu de chances que ça rien
puisque cette dame 69 sél pierre et va
bouger
jouer je pense qu'ici les trois
résultats sont possibles elles cachent
et je ne sais pas trop pour la rumeur
question peut toujours y avoir 6 passes
ont des coups bas
la chasse au tome 3 part il ya une forme
de rivalité est clairement après qu'est
ce qui se pratiquait qui pratiquent pas
dans les faits tout peut se dire et son
contraire je n'ai pas accès à toutes les
informations non plus les choses qu'on
peut pas nous confirmer aussi l'étape
d'hier reste encore un point
d'interrogation et on a pu voir que je
voudrais être en reste a été possible
n'a pas loupé la perdu ça tape du fonds
aria et du couteau qui nous a été très
très prompts à le battre avec juste ce
tandem et vahirua et du coup c'est une
belle victoire
alors voilà on a quasiment fini grand
maître gims gc lui met la pression
je crois quand on regarde ces parties
très serrées 33,6 duel de bambi stream
dalle qui rappe et une imprimante pour
géant g il évoque une torride donc on va
tourner parce que il ya de plus vraiment
d'espoir alors barda
ban qui a les noix qui commence une
partie contre sheth f4 alors normal qui
est largement favori mais voyons
sculpture d'un petit peu beknown ici
bien sûr que je vais bessac la
thématique c'est à 4 pour empêcher les
noirs de chrome de l'espace il n'a pas
joué donc dans l'amour ok c'est pas
précipités sur le bessin parce que
j'aurais certainement fait à pacy donne
son fou avec les noirs je pense pas que
sur la meilleure décision positionnelle
v auquel oui effectivement dans le cas
je regardais plus est passé dans cet
ordre là ouais il a racheté 13 au 24 mai
à laval s'est pris un refus il voulait
racheter de nietzsche est ce qu on lui a
dit non vie s'est rabattue sanchez 24 et
ensuite ils installaient un peu
forcément son équipe aux manettes la
bête c'est un peu la console argent-là
pas forcément la même mentalité que chez
nous mais plus tranquille ici on vous
propose plein de contenus gratuits
samedi je vous rappelle on a vraiment le
gros événement médecins sans frontières
avec maxime qui sera supervisé la dragon
sympa je pense etienne bacrot fab et
mathieu vous samedi soir sera au gourou
stream a les détails ce genre de détails
la moelle kashi demeure demeurent
secrets une bonne idée pour le co
alors du coup pour l'instant mais encore
une fois on se rend compte que le joueur
bien moins classés des fois on souvent
très bien et j'aime ça parce que sur un
seul petit coup on va voir si c'est
encore le cas ici aussi
4 nous fait mentir car sa position est
tout à fait ok leur barbarie a dévissé
de prendre plus d espace mais fou le 3
août c'est bien joué ensuite on va jouer
f4 on décide peut être un peu faible
la plus d espace on attend votre
cavaliers parfois on va le recycler
paris six f4 pareil quand même très
naturelle à pourchasser ce cavalier
j'aime bien les blancs et la paire de
four il a joué quatre ou cinq
ça peut être très bien leur flashy je
pense que c'est pas une bonne décision
ce que pour vous il jouait pas trop
alors que note on retrouve a été très
intéressant je n'avais la paire de
photons vouloir forcer à tout prix cet
échange s'est pas spécialement bénéfique
parce qu'on va se retrouver que notre
mauvais vous lui il bat yves derrière
nos pions en apprenne falloir envoyer du
f4 jour ou l'autre
salut d'haïti killer oui après il ya des
modes aussi les joueurs jouent sur un
site puis sur arnold
mais je pense que globalement
internautes d'interface chess comme hey
[ __ ] s pour rejouer son argent
nourriture
les deux ne vise pas la même chose et
propose pas la même chose sur une chaise
comme beaucoup plus doute si vous faire
progresser notamment les leçons
il ya aussi un gros contenu
journalistique d'articles les vidéos
avec événements qui sont souvent voilà
lié à directement de chez scott mais
avec 10 très bien un gros partenariat
sur litière c'est vraiment le plus
simple pour jouer voilà sa série non
c'est pas si ali reza va prendre la
place de moudia de carl scène c'est
évidemment son plus jeune sérieux
candidat prétendant le plus doué il n'y
a aucun doute là dessus
mais là deux joueurs qui à son âge était
extrêmement doué qui n'ont pas franchi
le palier ultime est tellement de
joueurs extraordinaires que ce n'est pas
de leur champion du monde malgré tout
son talent ali reza i la patience
or moi je suis souhaitant mais s'en fout
complètement vous direz mais en tout cas
on sera dans quelques années
jusqu'où jusqu'où il parvient à l'est
ali reza qui habite achats en france
pour ceux qui ne le savent pas encore
ça fait un petit moment maintenant ils
avaient en ménage l'été passé pendant je
peux en france joue pour le club de
chartres avec sa famille en france
et d'ailleurs il y avait là la fameuse
interrogations sur sa nationalité parce
que la plupart des joueurs iragne décidé
de prendre un autre drapeau et d'autre
la fidh en attendant et alireza espérer
crois pas qu'ils prennent le drapeau
français pour l'instant c'est toujours
en attente mais vu la situation actuelle
toute façon ce n'est pas la priorité
je pense pas qu'il se battra pour
l'instant d'après ce que ça peut
toujours être une question gros sous en
pâtit donc si on les fait une offre
qu'il ne peut pas refuser
il ne refusera pas mais en tous les cas
vient d'arriver en france malgré tout
donc ça veut dire que avec son père je
sais pas exactement les détails ont fait
ce choix il est encore jeune c'était
d'avoir stabilité aussi je pense que si
au bout j'ai chaque année dans un autre
pays pas les perdre pour lui verser
valent au passage de gaza au
bouillonnement tu l'as dit je regarde en
même temps dans le chat s'était bien
pour les blancs il a quitté l'iran la
raison principale c'est que la
fédération irakienne interdisait aux
joueurs certains tournois parce qu'elle
ne voulait pas qu'il rencontre des
adversaires israélien évidemment c'est
la raison bas il acceptable d'un point
de vue moral pour la majorité des
joueurs donc du coup il ya plusieurs
très forte joueuses iraniennes aussi
grand maître fait mineur il ya des
arbitres internationaux chirurgie à
plein ou décidé de ne plus défendre
crapaud la fédération virale et donc par
défaut le ca passe moi c'est de prendre
jouer sous le maillot entre guillemets
de la fidh on attend de prendre un autre
pays pour des raisons politiques voilà
l'a fait mais vraiment il avait une
interdiction même par exemple il
n'aurait pas dû jouer tel ou tel
championnat du monde de rapide s'il
avait gardé le maillot le drapeau pardon
alors je pense pas qu'ils soient
interdites séjour non plus encore dans
leur pays mais ce qu'ils y sont les
bienvenues débat sur la situation
politique là-bas est très tendue donc du
coup l'idée de tassement priori pour ses
choix c'est pas de faire machine arrière
par ci un changement radical qui
s'opèrent vous pouvez re de mots mais
peu de choses que ce soit le cas et je
sais papa lui quelle a été sa décision
il te sont tous les joueurs dans
l'absolu tous les joueurs plusieurs dû
déclarer forfait dans une partie où il
allait affronter d'israël donc presser
leur choix de vouloir s'expatrier ou de
respecter ça même sans forcément le
cautionner en attendant on va lancer une
autre partie entre y furent ya est
d'ordre c'est pas la langue dans
l'ouverture et ludiques ou de jouer
seulement au fait pour voir ok on va
dire que oui devrait changer d'âme
voilà c'est exactement ça ciel oui
effectivement je vous rappelle que
tabata pays
la fa si la reprographie et pour le goût
à déjouer quand il sera à lire et ça ne
m'avait pas plu donc du coup il retient
leur délégation
je perds du monde de rappeler bon opus
on a vu pire roja il a terminé vice
champion du monde de rapides donc
s'arrêter quand même très dommage de se
priver de sa présence il a énormément
apporté au tournoi ouais je crois que tu
as vu un tas de trop mais ça va ça passe
ta ta ta ta
[Musique]
du coup cette position dans la perte de
fou pour les blancs il faut cavaliers
dans tour isolée mais notre cavalier
quand même pas 500 go joués m6 a
abandonné voilà ou directement coup ça
va pour les noirs c'est assez solide ce
cavalier en restant qui va être chiant à
déloger si on mange
bon on se retrouvera avec ou contre vous
remettra la structure des noirs bien
donc c'est relativement égale ouais
c'est bien beau pic à la politique dès
l'instant toute façon la politique en
telle influence sur les échecs c'est
qu'il ya quelque chose qui cloche en pas
normal du tout d'interdire des joueurs
de jouer contre d'autres joueurs pour
des raisons politiques religieuses ça ne
devrait pas arriver
mais du coup si c'est pire aux âges se
retrouvent à jouer pour l'équipe de
france
cela sera une aubaine pour nous et on
n'en est pas là je sais pas du tout
financières bosser la fédération
française aussi peut faire des efforts
par rapport à ça ça coûte de l'argent de
prendre la nationalité pour un joueur
car même si les débats sont beaucoup
plus simples que pour prendre la
nationalité
sans parler de la dimension et chic est
donc juste d'un point de vue la loi
c'est plus facile d'avoir juste le
drapeau on sait pour jouer des tchèques
il faut payer et après je pensais un peu
d'investissements dans l'absolu il ya
des chances qu'il devienne champion du
monde ouvre un challenger dans les tous
meilleurs mondiaux donc cet
investissement il sera un retour sur cet
investissement aura il s'est passé quoi
il ya un très mauvais
ici j'ai pas compris les anticiper avec
noah il a fait échec il après mon retour
ces deux voix il a ripé non vraiment il
a un très beau tour ces deux comme s'ils
avaient anticipé autour des reins qui
n'a pas un sport je sais pas c'est
l'inconnu cette partie du coup ce
termine bizarrement
permettrait d'avoir une relève de relève
à elles veulent nous dit alouettes parce
que prince a aucun joueur pour prendre
la suite le niveau des nouvelles façons
c'est très rare c'est pas trés camp si
c'est un de temps en temps un joueur qui
peut te reste et les premières places
d'honneur 2e etienne bacrot qui était
extrêmement doué l'est peut-être le
potentiel pour être un bon dans les tous
meilleurs mondiaux il n'est pas allé
jusqu'au bout de son potentiel peut-être
pour après diverses raisons à la 10e'
fait que la shoah lautier avant lui très
très bons joueurs dans ce monde à maxime
bien sûr d'être le meilleur joueur
français de tous les temps alors on n'a
qu'à l'âge contre cryptage on va
regarder ça je sais que hier ils ont
joué ensemble s'est terminée par une
finale qui a une revanche à prendre pour
kalach mennecy part pas favori alors là
c'est l'agglo il a fait le grand roque
avec le fomc est au camp de contredire
j'ai pu y avait des sound shapes tout à
l'heure et oui et la relève de maxime il
peut ya voir boris il m'a dit c'est la
génération ou encore pas juste après
celle de maxime mais pas encore qui
vient encore ensuite parce que il a quel
age battles d'avoir quatre ans 13-14
maintenant je sais par un dos tres en
tout cas mais voilà quand ils sont aussi
jeune c'est quand même difficile de
prédire jusqu'où ils pourront aller et
dans les joueurs qui ont une vingtaine
d'années et qui sont ici même bien sûr
très bon ben ya maxime lagarde match
entre une france actuelle est aux
alentours de 2660 j'ai une boussens qui
est aussi très très talentueux dont
après est ce que ce sont deux joueurs
capables d'aller aussi haut que maxime
moulin blanc ne pense pas mais en tout
cas atteindre 27,6 boss
ça semble plausible a encore une fois
c'est l'histoire d'une motivation aussi
bougeront pas forcément aussi de poser
des chèques huit heures par jour pendant
x ap ça changera pas forcément d'être
2650 2700 elles seront plus heureux en
étant de 1650 mais en faisant d'autres
choses à côté alors dû ici les blancs
sont pas mal on va peut-être une
surprise encore une fois il ya 800
points de vente cryptage dadis depuis le
début du tournoi il est impressionnant
et finalement je crois en viande 14 mais
relativement solide
est-ce qu'on va se diriger vers une
finale ce qui est bien sûr dame problème
ici c'est que sa force g prend c'est
dommage
ainsi d'après si c'était le bon coup à
prendre de la tour parce que il ya la
tour en l'air sa forte j'ai pris et
maintenant ce qui met un petit peu
faible et surtout ce qui est important
au final l'activité des droits et on a
lui qui est coupée et notre 3 c3 est
très à joindre la croix l'attaqué des
plus adverse et c'est ce qui fait que
les blancs malgré la qualité matérielle
la symétrie la structure ici aurait
quand même un bon avantage
bon dieu de quoi bien voulu garder les
dalles vierge le tour des quatre finales
on est vraiment il a voulu à tout prix
garder la main c'est dommage parce
qu'une femme qui rêve de maintenance et
le pion il se retrouve alors malgré tout
il est pour l'instant sous contrôle
parce qu'on a les deux pièces contre la
promotion toujours des petites âmes sur
jet set elle pion à 5 en prison que les
plans sont pas si mal même si pau est
très dangereux on peut essayer de le
gagner tout de suite
moi je pourrais dames le sac ou d'amd
deux pour me débarrasser d'eux
danger quand même si aucun moyen avec la
tour devenir en défense du pion de deux
boucles avec les blancs c'est le moment
où tu cherches tu peux ne pas se tromper
ok tu quittes chez ba écoute merci
d'avoir participé peut-être à la reine
de ce soir alors il a bouclé à 5 mais
parce qu'ils jouaient épreuve world b6
la course est très mauvaise mais je
comprends pas pourquoi ils s'entêtent à
ne pas essayer de bon j'ai eu deux sens
quand même le truc qui saute aux yeux
j'arrivais jours mais cette position par
le danger on va tout de suite que cette
formule 2 de la priorité c'est de s'en
occuper et de joueurs ont l'air de
complètement ignorés ils font comme
s'ils n'existaient pas il ya tout près
d'eux parce que la dame prend un but
derrière il est alors là ça va être
important pour les blancs c'est un petit
peu soulager la tension
la dame qui est surchargée qui défendent
et la tourelle pions c'est typique
ça provoque des tactiques alors
maintenant les blancs - qui ont de plus
un roi mieux dans sécurité le drudge
d'être la pendule peut être ici et c'est
ce qu'il faut échanger les dames tour
éviter dames 4 me semble être une bonne
idée que la finale de tournoi gag est
perçue en échange les dames ce qui va
être très fort je rappelle la grosse
force ici des plans c'est l'option aura
joué b4 à s'inscrire à tous passés qui
va aller très très vite
qui va être dur à rattraper
citi passée s'est passé que les blues
ont enchaîné les mauvaises décisions en
lâchant le pillage 300 en raison du coup
c'est une position maintenant je pense
assez égale les compliquer dans le genre
de position la différence et l'eau et la
différence de temps je veux quand même
un rôle très important est apte à parler
trop vite comme moi ciel au maitre gims
qui a joué deux fois contre eux cryptage
c'est le reste par des appareils mais on
va faire attention aussi le thème de
bahts sur cases noires mais l'avantagé
noir c'est qu'ils peuvent tout de suite
lancé leurs pions alors ça c'est pas une
bonne idée de la part de de la part des
blancs les parents ça devient difficile
âge que vous faites le roi qui était
plus à l'abri ce retrouve un petit peu
en mode gruyère mais surtout balas et
les 15 secondes pour la vie qui vont
faire différence donc ça il part à
l'abordage je sais pas pourquoi il ya eu
ce courage 4 qui est qui va mal tu n es
pas vu le coup et quatre matins examen
derrière les deux dames s'imbriquent
dame ces trois là pamatai milpark où tu
vas courir beaucoup plus vite à
l'exception de la finale
gates incroyable cette partie cryptage
qui craque complètement la dame qui est
défendue par la tour si juste il a buggé
il a cru qu'il faisait le le thème
classique des déviations du roi xve pour
la dame pour lille adam sauf qu'il y
avait la tour ceccato alors qu'il a des
maths est coupable
on va voir si avec toute cette généreuse
et cryptes aliens clash arrive à gagner
encore faire attention aux pions mais
normalement ici elle devait faire
décalage qui est pas toujours
donc si les gayant à petit que son talon
d'achille
du coup ici au pc d'échanger les dames
pour simplifier club lyonnais mais
surtout ma tête tout va s'avancer tout
guérir la question ce qu'on a trois vous
êtes très vite paraître cher de secondes
par coup c'est de remonter un peu à la
pendule penser comme ça avec la position
est très facile à jouer pour pas risquer
de tomber et va tomber les domaines je
passe cilag un petit peu c'est juste la
main qui tremble
c'est la performance mais si vous n'avez
pas le droit de tomber que vous avez
deux secondes à part c'est un problème
de connexion bien sûr toujours un coup
notre porte et qu'il n'y a pas besoin de
calculer l'adversaire peut faire aucun
échec vous craignez rien on voit que son
roi il est dans les courants d'air vous
passez derrière blue da seul ou menaces
des échecs s'est terminée là votre
cerveau reptilien doit prendre le dessus
et il faut jouer et ne pas perdre autant
de titres aux aubettes ce qui fait que
vos placements aux cryptes heil à 10 9
sur 19 73 points devant ville 72 38
points donc là je vais pas vous la
phéromone suspense ça va être un petit
peu tu à montréal follet y connaît pas
sa meilleure année là 10 sur 12 malgré
tout stressé l'homme derrière de
cryptage
alors quelles parties à l'ets emmanuel
guerre contre marconnet on est en milieu
de jeu marconnet premier à faire passer
le gros craquage en parc ou dans une
position où ça a joué les blancs étaient
certainement assez peu mieux avec un peu
plus mais juste angèle 6 bat merci manu
te remercie du coup marconnet barco des
mois peut-être pas le regarder souffrir
jusqu'au bout avec une tour de moi ça
près
pas forcément un grand intérêt c'est de
voir une autre partie alors là on a une
finale qui est nul
pour ceux qui ne le savent pas dans le
chat ou pas
j'ai regardé les finales de tous avec un
tourne plus cela dépende de pain de
facteurs mais que c'est un pion h ou à l
embryon d'une colonne extrêmes là nul
mais est beaucoup plus facile parce que
toutes les finales de roi sur notre roi
c'est à dire qu'ici suffirait dans
l'absolu au blanc au noir bardon
d'échanger des tours pour faire annuler
surtout le roi est très loin du pion
donc en aucun cas notre foi peut
accompagner notre tous les gros problème
vu qu'on est sur une bande ne peut pas
se cacher quand la torah grâce qu'on
fait des échecs on veut pas se cacher
derrière d'autres plus vrai qu on sorte
de l'échiquier sinapian ici on peut se
cacher derrière lui ou à acheter avec
nos trois avec le courage c'est pas
possible
ici il suffit juste d'aller cueillir le
pion tranquillement pour le noir est
retrouvé le tour contre tours ou que
coralie devrait sans problème sécuriser
la nuit voilà salue lui le x vous allez
deux secondes avec fouet trois pros
contre vous n'avez pas le droit de faire
tomber le roi albert ii toujours le
droit de faire tomber le roi adverse
c'est pas cette paille car ou qui me
contredirait alors là une partie mais ça
se passe pas très bien pour mettre 10
c'est terminé derrière on
je suis pas le voir aller alexis avec
les noirs avec la petite mobile stream
contre boire tueur voir tueur tchamou de
lots mais ok on va voir ce qu'il fait
car pour l'instant ça peut se sauver ok
alors là une petite fourchette même pu
concéder fordham on peut faire d'am dam
d avoir des images chocs l'échec d'abbas
3 le problème c'est qu'à cannes qu'avez
vous pensé de ici en les deux joueurs
qui vont rater qu'elle ait procès de
kate est quand même relativement yvetot
le cavalier des fois aussi aussi si si
mais c'est moins grave de perdre deux
sites il n'y a pas de tours derrière un
nom qui est français c'est encore pire
puisque c'est la fourchette
cette fois-ci alexis bien sûr laisse pas
passer cette occasion
marcoux dewey après dans une arène 12h30
les gaffes comme ça ça arrive même des
mots meilleur faisait référence avec
elle mais à trop de trop de références
pour moi c'était trop loin de tempérer
cet épisode entre autres viandes rouges
avec un appel des syndicats devaient
gagner avec juste son seul fou la
frontière et tourner la page pensais que
tu voulais dire l'anversois le
convaincre qu'ils avaient les trois
pions et ça c'était bien sûr assez
dramatique un point pierre rochât mais
bon il y eut un peu la tremblote en même
temps elle tomber toutes ces pièces à
chaque course et 40 cents
il a joué assez normal moi je pense que
hello magazine est pas mal d'expérience
là suffiront cher mais c'est sûr que
c'était une forme d'injustice mais par
contre tout à fait car c'est tout à fait
tout à fait normal mais aucune polémique
à avoir là-dessus
juste l'histoire du fait que quinze au
départ est amené dans la partie dit un
truc en norvège en août après une
histoire d'interprétation du règlement
aussi normalement la paroisse de paris
être déconcentré son adversaire donc
c'est vrai que les arbitres auraient pu
intervenir et lui donner partie perdue
après est ce que c'est ça qui a fait
perdre 6 rouges à nous donc
mais le règlement était plutôt contre
15,1 dans la tribune brême après c'est
que les arbitres n'interviennent jamais
dans ces circonstances que c'est plus
aux arbitres ici qu'on peut faire des
reproches si vous fêtez reprocher à
quelqu'un alors du coup il ya aussi une
tour de plus et donc la alexis
d'emballement de la mort g m2 et ne
devrait pas trop pénaliser cette partie
menace une découverte et prend des 6 10
c'est pas mal joué mais malheureusement
avec la tour de moi il parle de trop
loin la voiture voir une partie un peu
plus et rennes j'ai l'impression que
j'aille à une tour deux mois pour un
camp vous savez pas beaucoup
[Musique]
allez tout n'a pas regardé futur
aujourd'hui turquie à d'habitude si nos
arénas contre thomas de jouer avec un
placement à ses proches en plus des
sorties de la phase d'ouverture et on a
une position assez intéressante si si on
plante jouer donc la question c'est est
ce qu'on mange chaud fou de cases
blanches comme ça je reviens répondent
oui
ce que j'aime bien manger la paire de
fou après autres cavaliers 24 quand même
assez fort les noirs vont sûrement le
coup et sept sur les stations comme ça
c'est bien là l'une des fonctions de
conseil 4 verra décidé à base de hassen
pour mettre une pression sur le ps est
ici là il a invité moi j'aurais plutôt
pensé à tours fc est c'est à dire qu'on
trouvait la septième manche et est du
coup à cinq voix tempo par thomas une
future va concéder le pion bessette pas
forcément à forbach a qu à l'époque
n'aime pas trop les petits dessins barre
avant les boeufs en silicone salut 20 20
en 2020 il reste 17 minutes
j'avais quand même une instru mais c'est
vrai que là est un peu short su faire
gonfler le nombre de participants un
droit quand même mais ouais
effectivement semble peu juste alors
qu'est ce qui s'est passé par papa
projet course est assez mystérieuse ici
et là problème cette des rebelles
ressortaient faisait pas offert mes
droits si c'est à priori et ensuite on
aurait pu la libérer tranquille monde
c'est un camion qui valait le coup
d'être pris
pourquoi du coup il a toujours le nez
qu'elle était matériel et maintenant
culture qui n'est plus dans le dur on
voit que ces chevaux assez offensive la
hardt au galop que j'ai pas trop ou
parce que les purs adverse sommes archi
archi protéger mais c'est vrai qu'on est
roi c'est plutôt pas mal
c'est comme une finale donc va falloir
un jour y sont rois
objectivement ici le résultat devrait
être là nul oui bien sûr ça va me dit
tout peut se passer
ça commence quasiment toujours à la même
heure dans 20 autres
13h15 13h30 ou plus tard c'est très
énervant aujourd'hui prend l'antenne à
13h a pu rouler c'est un peu les gens
arrivés petit à petit notre ce soir par
contre sa dot s était dispo à 20h30 une
grosse à rennes avec la fédé tu me
parlais plus tôt tu peux t'inscrire mars
à 19h30
laura kevin keith trimera et du cou ou
du savon partenariat avec la fédé il y
aura sûrement beaucoup de joueurs et je
me demande si rappaz auryn si par
exemple je ne suis pas sûr il m'a semblé
voir passer un truc peut-être dans les
affiches ou si vous voulez vous frotter
une petit prodige et tant qu'il est
encore j'étais encore preneur mais déjà
c'est déjà compliqué en tout cas
davantage que dans certainement quelques
années n'hésitez pas à vous inscrire
vous devriez trouver les infos sur czech
comme sur facebook
dans l'après-midi des postulats tout à
l'heure après le stream et salut à quoi
liée au montant
ce final a évolué avec une pièce qui à
disparaître l'instant qu'à cannes
beaucoup aujourd'hui de la fatigue de
degas fond d'un fou on fait des partis
qui sont plutôt bien joué puis d'un seul
coup c'est l'absence et la suite dirigés
vers la nul donc battons pour sauver sa
culture va devoir être très ingénieux là
autant si le pion des n'existait pas
loin des petites choses pratiques en
liquidant les choses et à l'exception
des passes ça devrait être possible
normalement nous sommes partis à la can
alors elle gâchis une question
intéressante je pouvais remonter dans le
temps pour les joueurs emblématiques je
jouerai j'ai la chance de faire un
blizzcon kasparov sur internet
du coup j'ai l'idée de kasparov puisque
c'est déjà fait m2 d'ailleurs
c'est quand même très tentant de choisir
fischer évidemment la réponse qui même
j'aime beaucoup de tables par son style
à extrêmement spectaculaire jouer avec
talent ça m'aurait bien plu aussi plus
souvent des gambier des sacrifices
peut-être que sa plume inspirée de jouer
avec lui
donc j'ai un fish out i'll voilà il se
bat quand même tu as avec les noirs une
finale font cavalier contre vous ce
serait nul face ils vont vraiment le
dernier obstacle à dix espions mais cet
obstacle
il est très solide ici alors il ya
presque les pièces les pièces blanches
se défendent un peu en retrait mais y'a
pas de problème parce que si on ne peut
qu elle y est le fou et à bout car le
roi sortir du carré il suffira juste de
plus celles qui ont servi un petit peu
par un fil
ce que fait thomas mais ça tient
normalement il devrait pouvoir voir
conclure mais peu de têtes qu'il espère
simplifier son fou sur le pion et après
cette pas sûr que tu tueur esquissé
bataille cavaliers comptent trois ans un
truc qu'on apprend l'action n'a jamais
appris c'est pas si facile surtout avec
une minute avec deux fous c'est beaucoup
plus simple avec deux cavaliers c'était
impossible à part si notre adversaire
est très généreux et donc du coup là il
a une bonne technique comment il a
réussi à forcer des changes et par la
même occasion l'abandon j'aurais bien
aimé moi qui font cavalier sort était
rigolo je vais arracher la nuit là tu
étais pas loin tu as tu aurais dû cesser
de sacrifier donc floue sur l'autre
peut-être que t'as pas pu
réglisse et on fout plus de votre côté
de l'échiquier doré une petite chance
alors on va se retrouver à l'aider à
retourner à d'autres leaders critères
mais il a encore gagné
donc il ya peut-être battre le record de
points d'arène partout il a 80 points je
pense que j'ai jamais vu ça 21 sur 20
heures quand mineurs avant il accable
réussi à faire une pointe et une partie
on sait poursuivons donc joué 15 16 sept
donc il a un précieux dans la crypte à
long terme d'efficacité on a vu qu'il
était foutu complètement dans une partie
avait gagné autant mais en tout cas ils
enchaînent marque tous les points là
j'aperçois poule pin à tort avec les
blancs ubeda tort contre il dit gilles
z06 paupinat temps qui met en avant une
position prometteuse grâce à la colonne
f ici ils attaquent le cavalier est
derrière car il a toujours est il qu'il
y ait bouya maths et les problèmes ici
pour les noirs c'est qu'il n'y a aucun
moyen de défendre le gall alliés ont la
tête ça n'aide pas dû cavaler double
bass a permis une pièce où pina temps
qui a l'air d'avoir très bien joué ce
que je pense que le fou impôt plus que
lecavalier
c'est une bonne question pour lui adore
ça c'est une considération qu'on a en
tout début de la partie haut sachant
qu'une partie peut prendre n'importe
quel tournant pour ça que gagner la
paire de fou c'est parfois d'objectifs
dans les ouvertures qui nous donne soit
zoo un micro avantage donc oui je suis
assez d'accord avec ça deux bases après
avis de la position évolué et donc selon
caractère de la position va évidemment
là je vais certainement rien à prendre
pour être assez généraliste les
cavaliers s'exprime bien revenue dans
les positions des rebelles s'ils peuvent
aller sur n'importe quelle case dans une
position ouverte un fou sera bien
supérieure grâce à sa capacité à être
une casse à grande portée de pouvoir
traverser tout l'échiquier mais c'est un
mur de piau
devant lui bat le fou souvent on dit tao
fuchs est un groupe option finance
j'aime pas un grand travail alors que
cannes a eu la possibilité de sauter un
peu partout après il ya aussi l'aspect
pratique en cavale
orbitz le cavalier c'est une pièce qui
souvent bas de par son caractère plus
imprévisible permet de placer des
tactiques de retourner des situations et
enfin en finale le fou est souvent plus
fort que le gall alliés pour le coup bas
grâce à sa grande portée parce que le
fou il peut à la fois soutenir un chiot
qui attaque et empêcher garder un oeil
sur un pur adverse qui menace d'al adha
il peut avoir un oeil sur les deux
extrémités de l'échiquier en tout cas
dit il est très lent va devoir faire
trois quarts sous pourra les arrêter un
pion ouais c'est ce sont les grandes les
grandes règles sur les foules et
cavaliers après bien sûr chaque position
grâce à sa propre vérité c'est un jeu
très concret les échecs donc ces règles
sont valables à dire 80 % du temps mais
toujours des exceptions et bafoue par
rapport à rien mais le foot est par
contre 100% du temps où quoi donc
poutine à tort ici bas gagner il a juste
à monter son roi créon petit réseau de
maths avec c'est un pion roi et tours
vous pouvez aussi aller ramasser à tous
les plombs c'est plus rapide mais c'est
le plus sûr cas c'est l'option qui l'a
choisi parce que j'aurais tout de suite
essayé d'amener mon roi pour mater ou
faire dame
hélas deux minutes trente ans il a le
temps il voulait psion il va se mettre
derrière lui va gagner facilement
lui faire confiance d'échangés de partir
est huit minutes dans cette arène j'ai
pu suspense pour la victoire finale et
deux joueurs que j'ai pas regardé encore
je crois que c'est un peu la fin de leur
parti est-ce de seconde à hâter nissan
leaf à lille pile pour perdre autant on
va pas le regard des graves at war gayet
ou kg trouver un truc en cours cyril of
à part fait un petit coup de sirène
vient de commencer contre notre ami
belge gora le 25
cyril offre en plus il a cohabité la
joute anti gambie mort assurent la
sicilienne sacrifier pour l'activité
typiquement pour la gare de fou pour les
cases noires et on va voir si ce
sacrifice il payant c'est le beau jeu le
beau jeu n'est pas toujours garant de
succès alors est-ce qu'on rend qu'avec
les noirs ou pas la question je pense
qu'on est quand même nécessaire de
mettre à l'abri le tir ok tu joues
étaient sympas ensuite il a reculé sont
pour s'enlever de celui à qui tu es
blessé quatre ont empêché des singles
chez moi c'est un enjeu important de la
position des 500 libérer un peu les
noirs ici je sais un petit peu dur
d'attaquer pour les plans ont sacrifié
un flou ils ont des compensations qui
sont liées à l'espace et au gaz noir jeu
ça que j'aime c'est que l'option à
défaut au dessus même si pour l'instant
il ya le cavalier 7 en l'air mais dans
l'esprit de cinq mois elle serait qu'à
l'air bien je suis pas sûr que ce qu'on
savait qu'il arrive à tenir à tenir le
coup parce qu'il est hors du cavalier g6
pour l'attaqué à une troisième fois
et du coup le pion à tomber
mais aura encore des petits thème
tactique de kehl éval
il s'agit avec un pote masqué dizaine
mis sur cale de quoi parles-tu donc
alors il n'a pas bougé de l'autre j'ai
pas trop quoi il a eu peur et pas de
clouage il pouvait défendre ensuite son
cavalier son problème là quand même
falloir urgence libéré par juif où
jouent et b to b sert des six les blancs
et ne veulent certainement recycler
leurs fouilles dans cette diagonale
c'était l'idée a priori de jouer le 5
mai lors du hqe attachant qu'il applique
aussi on ne l'est pas s'attaquer droit
cet incident fait une pièce on décide
qu'on a un très fort avant postes pour
bloquer le jeu des noirs avoir du sens
de m dès 6 h cartes aussi fois ci
j'avais pas vu c'est en finale
heureusement il ya c4 qui qui sauvait la
baraque mais ça libère un peu des
casques pour le noir est donc allée b 4
par est assez logique pour mettre la
pression sur le pion sert ensuite
sur les métadonnées je veux bien le
croire c'est là que ça a l'air grave
chaud je pense que j'aurais à coudray 1
sur 15
à chaque hoquet pas vraiment il va
implose mater plein sur h est prêt pour
l'instant le temps jouera 3d fois
pourchassés lequel elle est contre le c2
après c'est pas si facile à mettre en
place pour les blancs ces cartes est
très faible donc ne faut pas trop bougé
au b 3 du coup si rilov qui doit se
montrer ingénieux ici il installe une
tour de 6 là y'a une tactique alors une
cavale sans que c'est bien joué il ya
aussi à 4 qui est intéressant ou de
l'île fou le défenseur par une fois
derrière belle enfilade ses fans à paris
elle sacrifier la qualité ça jamais à
ces sacrifices de qualité dans l'esprit
pour mettre un pion l'a libéré cette
case pour ses pièces passons d'un porte
du matériel avec les bancs il est foutu
donc il doit tenter le tout pour tous la
taxe sur l'aura le problème principal
c'est ce fou qui ne fait rien qu'ils
roulent beaucoup trop passif
mais ok il ya des choses pratiques ici
la dame qui va venir on chez 4 il faut
que coralie soient très attentives
si les deux jours d'ailleurs autant de
terminer la partie reste trois minutes
ça devrait le faire fdj gorale il va se
mettre mal autant ici pourrait recycler
son fou dans la grande diagonale ou
jouer un peu comme cavalier c6 j'aime
bien cahier ces six là des matériels
d'avant s'il doit échanger des pièces
simplifier la position hamel surviennent
attaques sont
son avantage matériel fera la différence
3,7 j'aime pas trop on prend l'idée mais
beaucoup pratiquer sa part ouf quelle
est celle ci c'est bien est-ce qui va
concéder à les choses cyril offre
puisqu'il veut garder les pièces à tout
près genre jours aux cavaliers detroit
par exemple tu aimes pas très bon au
moins il garde des pièces si l'ap une
pièce nous pourra plus attaquées et g4
pourquoi pas mais ça reste assez
artificiel malgré tout quoi que doit
être leur pièce plutôt de ce côté là il
ramène sa d'amour défense
j'aime pas trop parce que ça va
permettre du coup ces deux on est
content d'enfin un mobinaute fouet les
gones allez maintenant commence à y
avoir des termes tactiques la dame des
trois dames achète damage fuite mat pour
l'adoption et 7 qui fait un bon boulot à
l'open sky songs ça que j'ai dit dam des
trois bad as me 4 parce que l 5
c'est la fourchette a alors oui le
problème en plus c'est quand il reculera
en d3 les mêmes paires production
laisserai dame à chalon peut prendre
deux donc ici f5 c'est un petit peu le
coup de grâce normalement il n'y a pas
été très précis là il s'est trompé de 15
points adam serov alors qu'il commençait
à voir du contre jeu le match et là font
manger ce qu'a d'ailleurs là il prend du
plomb c'est pas le mieux il réouvrira
gonalons vos raisons mais bien sûr il a
une tour de plus avec les noirs mais là
il est bon il ya des petits dtm rumba
dernière milieu déjà et ce qui va avoir
le temps de finir ma participation
obtient série love pourrait décider de
verdure et son temps à ne pas perdre
aussi maltais nous c'est jamais bien le
fils va gagner autant voilà c'est un peu
un schéma qui se répète
le joueur moins fort
vélo qui joue bien je retrouve gagnant
sur l'échiquier qui craque à cause de la
ponctuaient et du coup créer talent qui
reste 20 secondes donc on n'aura pas le
temps de relancer une partie
rip talent avec 24 sur 24
aujourd'hui il aura été impérial 93
points il n'est pas loin des 100 ch
conservant encore tout arrête confondues
depuis le début et d'ailleurs on a un
trio avec 51 points navimo des fohlen
alouette alouette babacar un bon endroit
quinzaine mischer du set
mais du coup ils sont tous très très
loin derrière cryptage donc bah bravo à
lui là aujourd'hui il est pâle
adversaire à sa taille
peut-être que ce soir sir jour pour
notre arène avec la fédé on voit qu'ils
parlaient invaincu en bus alouettes du
coup est vraiment vraiment pas mal 15 me
sur 17 3 nuls et quatorze victoires
je peste a rencontré un peu quelques
mecs de devant comme google follow you
vie mais en tout cas pas mal du tout
mais normalement à s'être le gros
objectif de ces termes de s'y faire
cryptage avec plaisir à il fut rien on a
vu en plus il ya plusieurs parties où
ils sont des sorties au temps où il
n'était pas très bien mais après il a
compris par des rennes fait je vais très
vite pour faire beaucoup de parties donc
il prend des risques mais au moins il
est prenable
franchement quelle que soit votre héros
vous avez une chance sur une partie il
faudra essayer de le faire tomber ce
soir la reine à 20h30
et on peut s'inscrire à partir de 19h30
là j'ai pas le lien d'inscription tout
de suite mais si vous suivez petit
stream sur facebook sur le club le club
du stream sur deux chaises comme chaise
comme français la page sur facebook
où le club france sur chelsea car vous
aurez les arts forains ya pas de
problème donc et si tu joues un
électrochoc téléphonique ce pôle
comprend bien que ça puisse mal se passe
departed difficile
elle reprend que la pac est déçu d'être
quatorzième après c'est dans un mouchoir
de poche
outre les places d'honneur une victoire
il va regagner 400 places là ça va très
vite
bon en tout cas je vous remercie tous et
j'espère que vous viendrez à l'ombre
nombreux ce soit pour cette arène qui
reviennent commentera prendra le relais
et du coup moi je vous dis à très
bientôt à l'aide portez vous bien